[تصفيق]
بالنسبة لملايين اليابانيين في
فصل الربيع ، يعني فصل الربيع شيئًا واحدًا عن
لعبة البيسبول ، ولكن ما لا يفكر فيه أحد المعجبين
بشأن ما يحدث لجميع
مضارب البيسبول المكسورة
جيدًا ، أحد مصنعي عيدان تناول الطعام
كإجابة نومورا ، وروح الفكاهة التي يتمتع بها شميد ،
مستوى HOF توماس رايش الذي لا يعرف الكلل  اسم ،
شكرًا لك ملكة جمال المنطقة ، حيث حصلت على
طعامك الرئيسي ، إنه رائع على المستوى الوطني ،
ستكون أحجام طاولة orotava بالفعل
سفينة حربية Scutari
ولكن أولئك الذين يعرفون Toki يحتاجون إلى السهم لأنني
تركت Domino إلى المقهى الوطني
[موسيقى]
كان قياس المسافة من العين أمرًا شائعًا
في صنعه  المنتجات الخشبية الجميلة
ومضارب البيسبول المحترفة ولكن بسبب
سوء إدارة الغابات ، كانت الأنواع
في مأزق ،
فماذا عن اسمه ، فأنا أرى ذلك ، لذا هل يمكنك التحدث بالصوت إلى اسم akalitis آخر Shimbun يوم قبلة كمين كمبيوتر محمول
كيف Domino أنت جاك أنت تعرف
Vitolo tanto ليس كذلك  كن محظوظًا ، حسنًا ،
يا جاك أيها الفطائر وتمت تسميته بعد
رمز k0 حسنًا يحدث ذلك بدلاً من
المساهمة في المشكلة السيد.
كان لدى المحامي فكرة عن مدى الهيمنة في الأفق على
الرغم من عدم وجود حركة
الجاذبية مع هذا السيد.  وضع المحامي
خطته موضع التنفيذ
باريتا للاستيلاء على الأسهم اليوم من
البامية الوردية الودية لا شك في أن
هذه الليلة قرنية
لا تقلق بشأن جوقة
سلطة الماشي الإيطالية صباحًا فقط
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مع أرباح عيدان لعبة البيسبول هذه
السيد  .  أو انضم إيتاني إلى
بطولات وفرق البيسبول للتبرع
لمجموعة تزرع غابة جديدة من Adamo
وتعامل
UN Jonah Sam Okinawan كريمًا ، أوه ،
غدًا ،
أنت تهتز ، أرى Hank أنت لست خبيرًا
اقتصاديًا R&L والذي يقوم عمومًا
بالقسطرة لك أو  ما هي رقبة جادة قابلة للتعديل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]